herzlich willkommen zu einer
außergewöhnlichen sternstunde mir
gegenüber sitzt der ehemalige us
vizepräsident und
friedensnobelpreisträger al gore am
diesjährigen zurich film festival
präsentiert er die fortsetzung seines
oscar gekrönten films eine unangenehme
wahrheit seine lebensaufgabe ist nach
wie vor der kampf gegen den klimawandel
vielleicht die größte herausforderung
vor der die menschheit je gestanden hat
und die zeit rennt auch für uns beide
denn wir haben nur eine halbe stunde
legen wir uns herzlich willkommen ergo
danke ja sie haben als sie in das weiße
haus gezogen sind haben sie sich eine
große biografie über das pult gehängt
und zwar ein bild der erde vom weltraum
aus gesehen und dieses bild wird eine
wichtige rolle für sie für ihren film
oder ihre filme und auch für ihre
vorträge die sie überall in der ganzen
welt erhalten
was löst dieses bild der erde bei ihnen
aus es gibt eine alte floskel dass ein
bild mehr sagt als tausend worte
für mich und für viele millionen
menschen auf der ganzen welt
dieses erste fantastische bild der erde
die in der dunkelheit des universums
schwebt etwas fest
über unser gemeinsames zuhause und
unsere beziehungen untereinander etwas
das man allein mit worten kaum einfangen
konnte ich glaube diese bilder von denen
es heute viele gibt wecken in uns ein
bewusstsein wer wir sind was unsere
lebensbedingungen sind und weshalb
unsere beziehung zum ökologischen system
der erde
zuoberst auf die agenda gehört weil wir
jetzt 7,5 milliarden menschen sind
wir haben die bevölkerungszahl in einem
einzigen jahrhundert vervierfacht und
weil die technologien derart mächtig
sind dass wir darüber nachdenken müssen
wie wir die verantwortung für unser
gemeinsames zuhause wahrnehmen wollen
hat die natur für sie ein wert an sich
also ist sie um ihrer selbst willen
schützenswert oder geht es ihnen eher um
eine frage der gerechtigkeit im
umweltschutz das heißt um zukünftige
generation also letztlich um den
menschen diese beiden werte schließen
sich nicht aus
die schwierigkeiten mit denen wir heute
konfrontiert sind sind zum teil auf die
falsche annahme zurückzuführen
sie seien irgendwie von der natur
abgetrennt natürlich sind wir das nicht
deshalb ja es geht um die natur
aber es geht auch um die zukunft der
menschheit wir sind mit der erde
verbunden das ist eine offensichtliche
tatsache 40 jahren mit dem klimawandel
und haben dazu beigetragen dass viele
wissenschaftlichen fakten ins
öffentliche bewusstsein getreten sind
etwa dass der menschliche co2 ausstoß
maßgeblich zu drei basiseffekt und zur
erderwärmung beiträgt dass dadurch die
polkappen schmelzen die gletscher der
meeresspiegel steigt und wie wir seit
ein paar wochen und monaten immer mehr
sehen auch die wetter- extreme zu nehmen
können sie sich noch an den moment
erinnern als ihnen klar wurde dieses
problem ist vielleicht das größte für
die menschheit insgesamt und sie wollen
ihr leben dafür einsetzen um dieses
problem zu lösen
diese zeitpunkt als ich realisierte dass
es sich in der tat um das größte problem
handelt mit dem die menschheit
konfrontiert ist liegt weit zurück
in den 1960 er jahren hatte ich das
privileg bei einem der größten
klimaforscher aller zeit
zu studieren einem mann namens broadway
eröffnete mir die augen all seine
voraussagen haben sich erfüllt
er war eine koryphäe auf diesem gebiet
aber ob schon ihr mir die augen dafür
geöffnet hat hätte ich nie gedacht dass
dieses thema für mich zu einer mission
werden könnte die hier alles abverlangt
das hat sich erst im lauf der jahre
entwickelt sieben jahre nach abschluss
meines studiums und meine militärdienst
zeit arbeitete ich als journalist und
wurde in den kongress gewählt dort in
washington dc begann ich zu fragen was
unternehmen wir in bezug auf die
klimaerwärmung
es war klar die meisten leute hatten nie
davon gehört und getan wurde nichts
so erhielt ich von meinem
ausschussvorsitzenden die erlaubnis das
erste hearing im kongress zur globalen
klimaerwärmung zu organisieren und ich
lud diesen großartigen professor als
kronzeuge nein ich war naiv und glaubte
er würde meinen kollegen im ausschuss in
20 minuten die augen öffnen so wie mir
damals in der vorlesung an der
universität nach diesem misserfolg
stellte ich mir erstmals die frage wie
kann ich dazu beitragen die aussagen der
wissenschaftler so zu kommunizieren dass
genügend menschen die tragweite der
herausforderung begreifen vor der wir
stehen
die zeit wurde ich immer stärker
hineingezogen
manchmal hat man dieses gefühl dass
niemand etwas unternehmen also muss ich
es tun
zum glück engagieren sich jetzt auch
viele andere
dafür bin ich den brut aktivisten hier
in der schweiz und der ganzen welt
dankbar nicht zufrieden wie sie langsam
dass vorwärts geht und sie bezeichnen es
auch aus ihr persönliches versagen und
wir schauen uns aus ihrem neuen film
eine unangenehme fortsetzung schuster
bauer einen kurzen ausschnitt
wir sehen mit wie viel herzblut dabei
sind
[Musik]
im unterschied zu anderen sozialen
bewegungen bürgerrechtsbewegungen geht
es beim klimawandel irgendwie darum auch
eine stimme einzuholen die noch nicht da
ist das heißt diejenigen die am
stärksten betroffen sind sind die
zukünftigen generationen und die haben
noch keine stimme wie muss die politik
mit diesem problem umgehen
das konzept von
generationenübergreifender fairness und
gleichberechtigung ist schwierig zu
kommunizieren weil wir als menschen von
natur aus den hang haben auf das hier
und jetzt und unsere persönlichen
umstände zu fokussieren
ein unterschied ist dass wir heute in
unserer zeit bereits von der klimakrise
betroffen sind
die stürme die sie angesprochen haben
jene der houston texas heimgesucht hat
war ein ereignis das einmal in 25.000
jahren vorkommt eineinhalb meter regen
in fünf tagen vor sechs wochen die bondo
tragödie hier in der schweiz ist ein
beispiel für ein phänomen das weltweit
an vielen orten vorkommt weil die
permafrost taut wie bei früheren
revolutionen wird auch bei der klima
revolution das problem schließlich auf
eine einfache unterscheidung eingedampft
was ist richtig das ist falsch
was ist wahr was ist unwahr manche sagen
in modernen gesellschaften sei die
unterscheidung schwieriger einige der
großen philosophen jürgen habermas
theodor adorno beschrieben wie die
kultur maschinerie die modernität den
kommunikationsraum mit verwirrung fühlt
und wie die bedeutung der vernunft
zurückgeht
adorno schrieb einmal
dass die umwandlung von fragen der
wahrheit in fragen der macht
die unterscheidung zwischen wahrheit und
unwahrheit gefährdet deshalb muss man
eine unbequeme wahrheit zu einer
wahrheit formen die sich in macht
verwandelt so wie mahatma gandhi die
formulierung kraft der wahrheit benutzte
er hatte dafür einen begriff aus dem
sanskrit wahrheit hat ihre eigene
spezifische anziehungskraft
sie hat ihre eigene stärke wenn es um
menschliche belange geht
und wenn sie klar genug kommuniziert
wird haben wir alle die fähigkeit sie zu
verstehen und zu spüren und darauf zu
reagieren
heute schwer denn die demokratie sei
gehackt worden
nein der aufklärung die alabama sagte
immer noch im gang ist
sahen wir den aufstieg von vernunft als
eine alternative quelle von macht die
ebenso stark war
reichtum und waffengewalt aber unser
informationssystem hat sich gewandelt
von einer zivilisation die auf der
gedruckten presse basiert zu einer der
elektronischen medien
dabei wurden zugangsschranken errichtet
um geld zu verlangen für den zutritt zur
öffentlichen debatte zum öffentlichen
forum jetzt aber sehen wir mit dem
aufstieg von internet und social media
eine dritte revolution
ja wir haben fake news und all diese
schrecklichen probleme die wir versuchen
in den griff zu bekommen
aber die struktur des auf dem
internetbasierten informations
ökosystems ermöglicht individuen nun
wieder sich am gespräch zu beteiligen
und schafft bedingungen die wieder zu
einem aufschwung der vernunft als basis
für kollektive entscheidungsfindung
führen können
wir sehen bereits reformbewegungen die
sich im internet verbreiten
die probleme müssen angegangen werden
man muss die echo kammern durchbrechen
aber eine durchschnitts person hat nun
wieder eine möglichkeit sich am gespräch
zu beteiligen und zur weisheit der
vielen beizutragen so kommen wir zu den
besten entscheidungen gemeinsam sind wir
gescheiter als einer allein fragt sich
jeder von uns auch was kann ich
persönlich dazu beitragen dass die
temperatur nicht weiter steigt und eines
davon ist zum beispiel weniger fleisch
zu essen das weiß man
oder weniger zu fliegen sie selbst leben
soweit ich weiss vegan seit einigen
jahren wahrscheinlich aus ökologischen
gründen nehme ich an
wäre es nicht auch zusätzlich zu einer
co2 steuer die sie fordern ein probates
mittel so etwas wie eine fleisch steuer
zu fordern
ich habe beschlossen ob zu recht oder zu
unrecht dass ich kein wanderprediger für
ernährungsfragen bin weil es mir
unangenehm ist ihnen zu sagen was sie
heute zu mittag essen sollten
das ist eine sehr persönliche war
ich habe mich vor fünf jahren dazu
entschieden veganer zu werden
als experiment ich fühlte mich gesünder
also blieb ich dabei alle ärzte sagen
uns dass wir mit einem geringeren
fleischkonsum gesünder leben würden aber
jahr das ist ein nicht unbedeutender
teil des problems ich kompensiere alle
emissionen die ich nicht vermeiden kann
ich weiß manche kritisieren dass grund
sagen dass er eine unzulängliche lösung
ich kompensiere allem eine
unvermeidlichen emissionen doppelt aber
ich bin überzeugt dass sich diese
botschaft möglichst wirksam vertreten
muss und ich hoffe dass jene die
versuchen kohlenstoffarme und
letztendlich kohlenstofffreie
treibstoffe für flugzeuge zu entwickeln
schließlich erfolg haben
ich denke aber dass das noch dauert aber
für die anderen bereiche des
transportsektors ich fahre ein
elektroauto und bin glücklich dass diese
fahrzeuge nun weltweit stark zunehmen
ich habe soeben weitere 520 solarpanels
installiert und meine erfahrung zu 100
prozent mit erneuerbaren energien zu
betreiben wir müssen alle unsere eigenen
entscheide aber als individuum mit
nutzen sie ihre stimme in diskussionen
über das klima nutzen sie ihr stimmrecht
die schweizer haben jedes für diese
sache wirkungsvoll eingesetzt danke und
nutzen sie ihre möglichkeiten bei der
wahl ihrer energiequellen und
technologien
so können sie teil der lösung sein und
senden sie eine botschaft an die firmen
und industrie dass es eine wachsende
nachfrage nach klimafreundlichen
lösungen und produkten gibt bei der
vorbereitung hat mich überrascht zu
lesen dass die kinder den größten
einfluss auf das klima haben also eigene
kinder
wer kein auto hat spart 2,4 tonnen co2
pro jahr
wer dagegen kein kind hat sport fast 60
tonnen co2 pro jahr
sie haben vier kinder müsste man den
leuten nicht sagen macht weniger kinder
und wie bei der ernährung erachte ich es
auch bei dieser sache nicht als meine
aufgabe den leuten zu sagen welche art
von familie sie haben sollten
global betrachtet sehen wir heute einen
starken rückgang was die größe der
familien anbelangt der demografische
wandel ist weltweit in gang
in verschiedenen europäischen ländern
und auch in japan fällt die geburtenrate
unter die reproduktionsrate und die
lösungen für viele unserer
herausforderungen wird
diesen kindern kommen jede soziale
revolution wurde teilweise von den
jungen angeführt sie haben eine
spezielle rolle
dessen sollten wir uns bewusst sein
übrigens wissen wir heute wie man den
demografischen wandel zu ende führen
kann
von einem gleichgewicht das auf großen
familien mit hohen geburtenraten und
hohen sterberate basiert hin zu einem
zweiten gleichgewicht von kleinen
familien mit geringen geburten und
geringen sterberate diese systemische
wandel tritt ein wenn wir mädchenschulen
und frauen stärken wenn alle die
möglichkeit zur geburtenkontrolle haben
so dass frauen und ihre partner wählen
können wie viele kinder sie wollen und
in welchem abstand
und wenn die kindersterblichkeit weiter
reduziert wird so dass eltern darauf
vertrauen und weniger kinder bekommen
[Musik]
ist denn die sache noch realistisch muss
sich jetzt fragen also ist es noch nicht
zu spät über halb die wende zu schaffen
und die klimakatastrophe zu verhindern
also in paris hat man sich ein 1,5 grad
ziel gesetzt und den kompletten ausstieg
emissionsfrei zu sein bis mitte des
jahrhunderts ist das überhaupt machbar
ist das realistisch ja definitiv
es ist definitiv machbar und realistisch
das tatsächliche ziel war ein anstieg
von maximal 2 grad celsius aber 1,5 grad
ist das ehrgeizige ziel
ich denke das zwei grad ziel ist immer
noch erreichbar
nun müssen wir uns aber bewusst sein
dass viele der klimabedingten
katastrophen die wir bereits haben mit
nur einem grad erwärmung eingetreten
sind
wir sollten also einsehen dass wir uns
mit einer mischung aus
schadensbegrenzung anpassung und leiden
arrangieren müssen
welchen mix wollen wir je stärker wir
die krise auffangen und begrenzen können
desto besser kommen wir weg aber wir
haben die fähigkeit dieses ziel zu
erreichen
ein berühmter ökonom der verstorbenen
rudi dornbusch sagte einmal bis etwas
passiert geht es länger als man denkt
dann aber passierte es viel schneller
als man es für möglich gehalten hätte
und diese art von exponentielle
veränderung wir kennen das aus dem
bereich der technologie mit dem
bayerischen gesetz mobiltelefonen und
vielen anderen geräten
es ist sehr spannend dass dieses gleiche
muster jetzt bei erneuerbaren energien
auftaucht bei der led beleuchtung bei
elektrofahrzeugen batterien bei
tausenden neuer technologien
die welt befindet sich gerade im frühen
stadium einer globalen
nachhaltigkeitsrevolution ermöglicht
durch digitale werkzeuge wie die
künstliche intelligenz das internet der
dinge
sie hat den umfang der industriellen
revolution aber mit der geschwindigkeit
der digitalen revolution
sie ist eine realität in unserem leben
und wir sollten sie als basis für echte
hoffnung wahrnehmen
wir können das lösen wir werden es lösen
bleibt die frage wie schnell werden wir
es lösen und wie groß ist die zuversicht
dass wir den point of no return nicht
überschreiten
niemand kann sie aufhalten
niemand nicht einmal ein präsident der
vereinigten staaten kann sie stoppen
ich gestehe ihnen als er vor ein paar
monaten diese rede hielt war ich besorgt
dass andere staaten seinem beispiel
folgen könnten
aber das geschah nicht am nächsten tag
war ich voller freude als die anderen
staaten weltweit sagten nein wir halten
am
riesa abkommen fest und in meinem land
haben die größten bundesstaaten
kalifornien new york und viele andere
gesagt wir sind immer noch teil des
abkommens hunderte von städten tausende
von geschäftsführern und jetzt steht
übrigens fest dass die usa ihre
verpflichtungen im rahmen des pariser
abkommens einhalten und übertreffen
werden und ironischerweise ist das
früheste datum für einen legalen
ausstieg der usa aus dem pariser
abkommen just der tag nach den nächsten
präsidentschaftswahl
hier muss man auch unterscheiden
zwischen donald trump auf der einen
seite und den vereinigten staaten von
amerika auf der anderen die usa sind
immer noch unterzeichner des abkommens
wir werden unsere verpflichtungen
erfüllen und übertreffen
darüber hinaus hoffe ich auf die
wiederherstellung einer
verantwortungsbewussten führung
das experiment mit der tramp
administration dauert noch nicht einmal
ein jahr
und wissen sie in medizin und forschung
werden manche experimente aus ethischen
gründen frühzeitig abgebrochen leben
auch viele klima skeptiker die haben
einen großen rückhalt
sie reisen seit einigen jahren
jahrzehnten um die welt und versuchen
die leute zu überzeugen
was ist für sie das beste mittel das
beste argument um einen klima skeptiker
zu überzeugen
ich stellte fest dass mutter natur die
überzeugendste advocaat ihn ist die
zunehmenden katastrophalen ereignisse in
zusammenhang mit dem klimawandel
beschäftigen die menschen
umfragen und politik wissenschaftliche
studien zeigen dass ein großer
sinneswandel stattfindet ich habe kein
mitleid mit den klimaanlagen aber
manchmal denke ich ihre last wird so
viel schwerer
jetzt müssen sie derart viel leugnen sie
haben wirklich ein problem
die usa sind ziemlich einmalig mit ihrem
harten gegen
satz von klimaleugner dafür gibt es
mehrere gründe
in meiner heimat tennessee im süden der
usa haben wir ein altes sprichwort wenn
man eine schildkröte oben auf einem
zaunpfahl sieht kann man ziemlich sicher
sein dass sie nicht von alleine dorthin
gekommen ist
auch diese anzahl von klima leugnern kam
nicht von selber die großen co2
verschmutzer amten das verhalten der
tabakindustrie nach als vor jahren
wissenschaftler den zusammenhang
zwischen zigaretten und lungenkrebs
sowie anderen krankheiten herstellten
engagierte die tabakkonzerne
schauspieler und verkleideten diese als
ärzte sie stellten sie vor kameras und
teleprompter um die menschen absichtlich
anzulügen und so zu verunsichern dass
sie glaubten es gebe überhaupt keine
medizinischen zusammenhänge die co2
verschmutzer gingen gleich vor sie
verpflichteten oftmals die gleichen
pr-agenturen das wort böse verwende ich
selten
es gab einmal einen philosophen mit
einer unüblichen definition des bösen er
sagte das böse ist die abwesenheit von
wahrheit ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man
damit die ganze bedeutung erfasst das
haben die leute durchschaut aber es gibt
weitere ursachen politische denker deren
höchstes ziel es ist die staatsmacht
einzuschränken befürchten eine stärkung
des staates wenn uns die tragweite
dieser krise bewusst wird und die
menschliche natur verführt uns dazu
unerfreuliche dinge zu verdrängen und
sie spielte auch in ihren filmen eine
große rolle es gibt viele bilder die
mich an biblische szenen erinnern
apokalyptischen bilder macht und von
überflutungen von von thyrnau
funktioniert angst besser als hoffnung
und die leute zu überzeugen
ich glaube ich dass hoffnung ein viel
größeres potenzial hat um leute zu
motivieren
aber es ist nicht unvernünftig die
konsequenzen zu fürchten falls wir nicht
handeln
aber wissen sie manche leugner ändern
ihre haltung
ich traf kürzlich einen mann dem ich
gesucht hatte sein name ist gary taylor
sie finden ihn im internet 20 jahre lang
arbeitete er für einen der rechten fink
tanks er hatte den auftrag klima lügen
zu verbreiten
auf einem flughafen kam ihr zu mir
fragte ob ihr mich sprechen könne und
sagte sie haben mich überzeugt ich
wechsle die seiten wie kann ich sie
unterstützen
europa macht im moment weniger die
klimakrise sorgen als die
flüchtlingskrise und sie sagen im neuen
film die beiden dinge hängen zusammen
gerade was syrien angeht ist die hängt
denn der klimawandel mit dem
flüchtlingsstrom zusammen die die
beispiellose klimabedingte dürre im
östlichen mittelmeerraum vor allem in
syrien und begann zwischen 2006 und 2010
lange bevor der bürgerkrieg in syrien
ausbrach forscher haben studien
publiziert die bekannteste ist jene der
national academy of sciences
sie stellte einen sehr klaren
zusammenhang her ohne ins detail zu
gehen
die klimabedingte dürre hat 60 prozent
der bauernhöfe in syrien zerstört 80
prozent der nutztiere getötet und über
1,5 millionen klimaflüchtlinge in die
syrischen städte getrieben wo sie auf
weitere 15 millionen flüchtlinge aus dem
irakischen krieg geprallt sind in den
wikileaks dokumenten findet man
konversationen zwischen syrischen
minister die lange vor dem bürgerkrieg
sagten
wir werden damit nicht fertig das führt
zu einer explosion
es gab auch andere gründe die zum
bürgerkrieg führten und die türen zur
hölle öffneten und weitere faktoren die
zum flüchtlingsstrom beitrugen
aber das klima spielt dabei definitiv
eine rolle
und natürlich haben die außergewöhnliche
welle und die zahl der flüchtlinge die
fundamente der europäischen union
erschüttert sogar die brics it
abstimmung in großbritannien eine den
stärksten werbungen der exit befürworter
zeigte eine endlose reihe von
flüchtlingen die aussahen als wären sie
aus dem nahen osten an den grenzen zu
europa und die botschaft war wir wollen
diese flüchtlinge nicht
es ist nicht nur aus dem nahen osten
nach europa indien hat soeben entlang
seiner südgrenze zu bangladesch den
größten metallzaun der welt
fertiggestellt
weil flüchtlingsströme aus den
überfluteten mündung regionen von
bangladesch diese grenze überrannt haben
es gibt viele weitere beispiele aus der
ganzen welt
das max-planck-institut in deutschland
hat kürzlich in einer studie
vorausgesagt dass gewisse regionen im
nahen osten und in nordafrika gefahr
laufen unbewohnbar zu werden
infolge einer kombination von steigenden
temperaturen und feuchtigkeit die
menschen werden aus diesen regionen
strömen die konsequenzen für die
politische stabilität sind also
erheblich das ist ein weiterer grund
weshalb dringend gehandelt werden muss
heute nähern sich wissenschaft und
philosophie einander an indem sie uns
lehren dass wir ein untrennbarer teil
der natur sind alle untersuchungen
zeigen
dass wir aufblühen wenn wir sonnenlicht
haben unter bäumen spazieren frische
luft atmen und sauberes wasser trinken
es klingt nach einer banalität ist aber
eine fundamentale wahrheit über den
menschen
wir wissen heute aufgrund kürzlicher
erkenntnisse dass wir zehn mal mehr
nichtmenschliche mikrobiologische zellen
in unserem körper haben als menschliche
zellen so sind wir innen wie außen teil
der natur wenn wir die wunderschöne
lebenswelt beschädigen indem wir
gedeihen schaden wir uns selber es geht
also nicht um nietzsches aussage die
natur habe keine meinung oder würde sie
nicht äußern
wir sind teil die natur und unsere
entscheide haben nicht nur konsequenzen
für die natur sondern auch für uns
selber ja auch nächste woche spricht
meine kollegin barbara bleisch am
philosophischen stammtisch über den
klimawandel und fragt dürfen wir noch
fliegen
zum ersten mal findet der stammtisch vor
publikum in basel stadt das sollten sie
nicht verpassen
und jetzt gleich verlassen wir den
bereich der politik und tauchen ein in
die welt der literatur der poesie und
der liebe
wir reisen nach paris in die wahlheimat
der deutsch französischen
schriftstellerin undine gründer kommen
sie also mit und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]